after college i found myself working for
the office of charles and ray eames
there were many people in there who were
filmmakers and designers
and i learned filmmaking and designing
at the feet of the master as it were and
when i decided to graduate myself from
the academy of charles and rayms some
foolish people in the film business
seemed to think i knew what i was doing
so i started working in the art
department of the film
business um the thing i'm asked most
frequently is what in the world
is the difference between a production
designer and an art director and why
is the oscar called the art direction
oscar when in point of fact it's never
been given to a so-called art director
for many many many years now that's the
one that i stumble upon
the most
we've worked to change some of the
language
um when the award is given so that it's
maybe the art direction category but the
award is given to a set decorator and a
production designer
that's one way where we've tried to
demystify the process but
art directors in general
are working for and alongside production
designers
we basically hire
them to help us
execute what has to be executed
um i think it's
sort of the old heraclition thing you
can't step into the same river twice
every time
you take another job you think oh my god
do i really know what this job is like
this time around because
people change
the rules about budgeting change
the rules about financing change
everybody's chasing the cheapest money
hither and yawn to far parts of the
universe that
have different requirements um i i don't
know how to say that except to say it
really is like a heraclitian river you
never know
when one job ends how different the next
one's going to end up being
um actually i think if i had to get up
every day and go to the same place and
do a similar thing every day for work i
would be
hopelessly lost and angry
you